all right guys
bang bang super pumped about this
episode
i have chris here with me um we are
proud investors
in level so thanks so much for doing
this man yeah really appreciate you
having me on palm
awesome let's get started uh for those
that don't know you your background
and uh what you did before you got into
bitcoin and crypto
yeah sure so i i was originally an
applied mathematician
and i studied mathematics at the
university of texas
and while i was there i developed some
computer vision technology
for tracking augmented reality headsets
so the basic idea was that you could you
could take these
virtual reality set headsets like the
htc vive and by putting cameras
inside of them that pointed out at the
world that you could track their
position without having to set up any
cables or
or base stations um and that was my
first foray into entrepreneurship
um we sold that business in 2015
and then we sold the business unit again
um
and from there i really just wanted to
take like a sabbatical
and and think about you know like what
would i like to prioritize with my
career and that was uh that was 2017
early 2017. obviously at the time crypto
was getting
a lot of attention um the price was
going up you know really from the second
quarter consistently
um but what attracted me to that area
more than anything was this idea that um
that could consumers could have better
financial outcomes by sort of
decentralizing power
within finance that decentralizing
through these protocols
and sort of who has leverage over money
um
having these transactions be verifiable
uh
that that ultimately could be like sort
of a boon
for consumers um and you know when i was
in my early 20s
uh when i was in my early 20s i i was
a victim of the you know the welsh fargo
overdraft scandal
they opened a fake account in my name so
i've always been really passionate about
um i mean i would say first i was really
mad i was really mad that that was
happening to me and then over time
you know i got passionate that working
in the crypto space is something where
you know you really have an opportunity
to tackle those challenges
uh and so we started with an indexing
platform that was our first product that
we introduced in crypto
and that uh that attracted some team
members that we still work with today
like willy woo jimmy song um
and you know as we developed the product
we really just said from first
principles
like how can we make the experience of
being involved in crypto
just easier to use some products are
doing a better job of that
than others but the two things that we
identified
was that it's really expensive to trade
on crypto exchanges
and it's not the easiest thing to do
it's a fairly technical experience
um and that's really what got us down
the road to uh to developing level
um which is the platform that we've just
introduced
got it and so what was the original
impetus for
level right in terms of you go down the
indexing path and then you realize wait
a second
there's this other path that we want to
go down we think we can build a really
compelling product that not only
is sustainable and kind of can be
profitable but also and more importantly
it can solve a number of problems for
users like
what were those pain points that you
identified or what was kind of the
opportunity
uh yeah so i think pain points is a good
way to do it and
this was really an incremental process
so from the moment we introduced our
indexing platform
we had a lot of smart people around the
table that have been involved in crypto
for a long time
really understood what it's like to use
the products today um these are people
like
uh jimmy song willywoo i think i
mentioned and
it was really a clear sequence of events
of solving
like what we thought were major customer
problems so first we released this
indexing platform and the biggest
barrier to using this indexing platform
was you had to first go and set up an
exchange account on something like
gdax is what it was at the time now
coinbase pro
or on finance then you would have to get
the api tokens
that would allow our platform to talk to
binance and place trades
and you had to put them into our
platform um
and since we were building something
that we really wanted like sort of like
dad and mom to be able to use
that was really not a great customer
experience right
um and so what we tried to do was
go talk to the exchanges and say you
know can we onboard customers
and then you know basically bring the
curious kyc information that we get
to you and then you approve the accounts
and
like we're going to be able to offer a
much more seamless experience than
having to go
set up two different products right and
the long and short of the answer we got
from the exchanges was like
we can like we're basically multiple
exchanges just said we'll
we're happy to buy you uh and integrate
what you're building into our product
um but we won't support it as a
third-party product
um and so um so we what we decided to do
was say like let's build our own spot
market
um that's the most fundamental thing
that these customers are
providing for these exchanges would be
providing for us let's build a spot
market
and so we built that spot market and we
launched it and that was our alpha
product the ability to place
market and limit orders on our own
exchange and all of that was
crypto only um and
that so first of all that got us a
little down the path of making
a better experience overall but it also
attracted more users to the platform
so now we had hundreds of people that we
could talk to to understand
you know like what is it that they like
what's missing now and so the next thing
that we identified
was that people um if you're really
trying to get mom and dad
to get into crypto uh they're not gonna
open a coinbase account by usdc transfer
usdc
over to our platform and so we very
essentially had
uh to basically offer cash services on
level
we needed to have the ability for people
to to start with just
cash and then get into bitcoin and have
a very
like easy user experience um
and so i think i think having to have
our own spot market
um and um and basically supporting cash
those are the two
main sort of observations that took us
in the direction of directly competing
with with coinbase and wells fargo
along the way there were secondary
things that would come up
um so how do we get liquidity on the
platform and we've decided to address
that
through the autopilot feature um which
i'm happy to discuss
uh that was a problem that came up for
example um
but it's been a very i think as much as
possible we've tried to make it
a natural evolution of
of delivering the the uh the product
that our small but growing community
was was looking for and so
it's very unique i think in this space
to offer uh
a cash product or a us dollar cash
product that's fdic insured
and also a crypto spot type product and
so maybe talk through just a little bit
about
you know one wire why is that so rare
like why do so few other people go after
that and then two what are the steps it
takes to kind of uh
run that dual process and get the
regulatory approvals to be able to even
offer this
yeah so um you know i want to draw an
analogy to a couple other platforms
that are a little bit like this um and
uh and and for that reason you know have
attracted a lot of users because there's
some clear benefits to this model
um so cash app for example uh you can
buy
bitcoin they just support bitcoin you
can buy bitcoin on cash app
and you can store cash on cash out
um another example would be robinhood
like you can you can buy bitcoin
on robinhood um you can't withdraw or
deposit though it looks like any other
stock um
now the way that we've built our
platform under the hood
is very different from from
those platforms in a couple different
ways so first of all the cash that
you're holding
in your level account is in an ftic
insured
demand deposit account and what a demand
deposit account is
is it's a bank account that is open
directly in your name
so when you sign up on the platform pump
you're going to get a cash account
and that cash account is a full ftic
insured
checking account and that means that you
know if something was to go wrong
in the general financial system or
something was to go wrong with our
business
the fdic will just cut you a check
directly now
robinhood cash app coinbase
they don't build around demand deposit
accounts what what they use is a type of
account called a custodial account
and the idea of a custodial account is
all the customers deposits get pulled
together
in one corporate account and then the
company keeps track
of uh basically how much money each
customer is is good for or should be
credited based on the current status of
their account
um and and and so what we we want to
basically make it so that
your cash is either in your name and
directly ftsc insured just like you
would have it at wells fargo
or it's been sent to someone else's
account because you bought bitcoin those
are the two
acceptable states for for for cash on
our platform
um so that's one big difference the
the second big difference is our
business model
um so i'm sure we'll have an opportunity
to talk about
you know uh our business model in
comparison to something like coinbase
we start it's nine dollars a month they
charge transaction fees
but i want to stay focused like
specifically on the sort of cash apps or
the robin hoods of the world
um so uh cash app and robinhood they
don't
operate spot markets what they do is
if you buy bitcoin they match that
bitcoin
to a market maker that they have a
relationship with
um and what a market maker does is let's
say the price of bitcoin is ten thousand
dollars
they're willing to sell you bitcoin for
ten thousand
twenty five dollars they're willing to
buy bitcoin from you for
nine thousand nine seven
um and that's called a spread that's
basically a profit margin that the
market maker is charging for their
services
and then they pass that profit to
to um robin hood or to uh
catch up that's how those platforms are
built now
our spot market is different we do not
market make on our own platform
um and so that that makes us different
from coinbase consumer robin hood
and cash up level never directly sells
you bitcoin
what we do is we have a product on level
called autopilot and when users fund
their autopilot account
it automatically market makes that
process that i just described
it automatically market makes for other
users so what you're doing is you're
taking your bitcoin and your cash you're
putting it to work
um and that allows other
users to buy on demand so it provides
liquidity for them
and in return you earn an income on the
profit margin that you set yourself
uh and so um i think you could safely
say that you know taking kickbacks from
market makers like
like robin hood and and cash have do i
think you could safely call that a
hidden
hidden fee um and on our platform there
is no
hidden fee that the platform charges
there's just a profit making opportunity
for other users
so this is really important right what
you're getting into is kind of all the
different business models
around financial services and exchanges
for these kind of consumer retail
focused applications so
you started out with first um just a
transaction fee
basically if i buy or i sell i'm getting
hit with
a stated percentage right could be 25
basis points could be 10 basis points
whatever it is
but there is a stated fee that i am
going to pay in order to
uh consu finalize this transaction so
that's
one uh coinbase most crypto exchanges
that's how they're making money
there's a second one which is the spread
that you're talking about so when you go
in
it says you're buying bitcoin at ten
thousand uh and twenty five dollars
there is a zero dollar uh transaction
fee right
you're paying zero dollars in
transaction fees but actually what's
happened is there's a margin that's
baked into the price at which you're
buying
the asset itself now you guys are
basically
going ahead and you are pioneering a
third business model which is very
interesting
and got us excited is you are saying
wait a second we don't need the
transaction fee
and we also are not going to include
spreads all you do is you pay us a nine
dollar a month
flat subscription fee doesn't matter how
much you trade how much you buy or sell
you pay us nine bucks a month and you
can use the service unlimited amount of
times
and that's your revenue sources that
nine dollars a month per user
compared to the transaction fees or the
spread so maybe explain a little bit as
to like
why the subscription fee and then how
that math works to make it attractive
for you to go after
yeah if you don't mind me looping back i
thought what you said about transaction
fees versus hidden spreads
was just like very spot on um
and uh i think one thing that's worth
noting they are they're different models
right when you charge a when you charge
a fee specifically on trading
that's called a trading commission um uh
and then you know charging a spread that
is like a
that's like a markup basically but in
some sense you could kind of view both
of them as transaction fees
it's just how transparent are you being
with the customer um on coinbase pro we
tell you exactly the percentage we're
charging
on coinbase consumer they have a spread
just like
uh you know robinhood does and they just
they disclose their commission
but they don't disclose their spread on
coinbase consumer then on robin hood
they don't disclose the spread at all
but really i mean both of them are sort
of like you're making a percent of the
customers order
um and uh and so
you know i'm only bringing that up
because like if we can call both of
those transaction fees i think it sort
of illuminates
like besides the issue of like you know
let's be as transparent
as possible when we're charging our
customers it seems like the least we can
do
um when you group them together as as
transaction fees
i think you can really start to sort of
to say like
are these transaction fees like
necessary just from an engineering
perspective
are they good for the customer um
and you know the uh whether you're
charging a hidden spread
or you're charging a commission and
these can be quite high
so you know if you place nine trades on
coinbase consumer a month
of 50 or less that's nine dollars you're
spending you spend if it's 51
you know that would be 18 you're
spending so these are quite high fees
now the first question and the spreads
are high too you know one percent on
something like robin hood
um so the first question is like are
those costs justifiable
like just like i think that's such a
fair question it's just like
like are these companies going to go out
of business like if they don't charge
those transaction fees
and you know the answer to that is like
they're actually totally not justifiable
because from an engineering perspective
uh when i buy bitcoin for new pump
all that's happening is your database
entry of how much bitcoin you have goes
down
my database entry goes up that's
milliwatts
um and it's objectively less complex
than something like world of warcraft
for example
which also operates on a subscription
model and does many more calculations
um in the administration of that service
so that's one reason where you can say
hey these transaction fees might not
make sense
right and then the other the other
reason you can say that they might not
make sense is
you know if these exchanges were just
barely skating by they wouldn't be
booking a billion dollars of net income
a year
right um that net income directly comes
from overpaying for services
so um so in a nutshell
we can afford to and we think it's more
reasonable to
charge a nine dollar subscription fee um
and you know other than just the value
savings which which can be
apparent quickly it's one trade on
coinbase pro of 1800
it pays for itself um the uh
if you do five trades on coinbase
consumer in a month uh
it pays for itself so other than it just
being a pretty
fast recuperation of value we also with
the membership fee we want to align
we want to align ourselves to not be a
transaction-based business
but to be a services-based business so
in a transaction-based business i'm
gonna make my money when you log on
if you're not logged on i don't care
about your account there's no reason not
to automate things
if you have a problem unless that
problem's about a transaction
i don't have a vested interest in
resolving it because i'm not going to
make money off
helping you recover your account for
example with us we assign a personal
banker to every level member
and uh you can talk to them right in the
app so most people right now are just
talking to clifford
and 40 of our users that sign up have a
conversation with clifford within the
first week
um i don't understand how this feature
works or
um you know i want to make sure that i'm
doing this correctly and so we're really
there to provide
a service to the customer that you can
tap at all times
instead of just showing up in time to
make money
and so i guess part of this is um
you said you can afford to do it but is
it
more profitable or less profitable to go
with the subscription-based model versus
the transaction fee model
um you know i think that
i think that remains to be seen um
it depends on it depends on the
distribution of customers like
the customer makeup and how much money
they're spending today
now as i i just mentioned a couple
thresholds like five trades a month it
pays for itself or one eighteen hundred
dollar trade on coinbase pro
um those are very low thresholds
um like like just pretty much anyone
that's active trade actively trading
right now
uh we are going to make less profit off
those guys right
um and so and so clearly that profit is
going directly back to the customer
we're not making it we will make less
money than coinbase in that category
now as we look into the future we're not
just building a low-cost crypto exchange
we have full ftic-insured accounts we
have free money transfers we have free
wire transfers
uh we have automation technology that's
completely automated
and included in your account um
over time we hope that this product
becomes something that
anybody can use right it's way less
technical than coinbase
you could refer it to mom and dad now
they have a product they can actually
use
and i think that expansion in the
addressable market you know just that
these people
that maybe were annoyed by coinbase are
finally willing to come use it
um you know it could be more profitable
in that regard just because
we can help more people
got it and so as you're kind of building
this out um
talk a little bit about uh the fdic
insurance and then the security on the
crypto side right because i think
one of the things that people see is
okay so you're telling me i have a
cash product and i've got a crypto
product those are two different types of
assets
um i'm very worried about security in
general just in the industry
and so how do you guys think about the
advantages of having fdic insurance on
the
cash and then also how do you think
about the security of the crypto
yeah so um so
i'll preface this by saying that you
know when people entrust us with their
money
um that is an extremely high
sort of bar of responsibility it's
people's vacation budgets it's it's
their kids college funds
and we take that very seriously and
especially as an emerging brand we want
to make sure that we're doing
as good or better of a job than the
incumbents so you can feel completely
secure about putting your
cryptocurrency on the platform um and
uh let me just compare to a traditional
exchange i think i think that would be
you know sort of the the best thing to
just draw could direct comparison to
so on it and i'm gonna i'm gonna answer
both elements of your question the the
cash side and the crypto side
so on your traditional exchange they
manage
i'll start with crypto so on your
traditional exchange they
manage their own code wallets and hot
wallets
uh that um that basically pulls all of
the customers
crypto together and that crypto is
considered to be
in the custody of that exchange so
they're responsible for making sure that
they have enough crypto at all times
that they don't get hacked they're the
single point of authority on approving
transfers
um that is the traditional way to handle
crypto
now what we've what we've done in our
financial institution as we've built
level
uh we want to decentralize that security
and
make it less likely that we would be a
point of failure
and so what we do is we work with a
company called bitco
and our wallets are multi-signature
wallets that require
two of three approvals um level holds
one
uh key so we can't send your money by
ourselves
uh we only hold one and it requires two
keys to send
another one is in stored somewhere safe
um in case either i us or bitcoin is a
key
and then the third key is in bitco's
possession and
with bitco we implement these
institutional policy controls
uh so um only so many withdrawals per
hour
of a certain value per hour like a net
combines value
um uh so bitco is required
it is in a second sign off but before we
even get there we also perform our own
internal reviews
um and uh
and our internal reviews what we're
looking for is
um we want to make sure that you have
sufficient account balance obviously
uh we look for patterns of suspicious
activity that might indicate identity
theft
we don't want people going on buying
crypto in somebody else's name
that whether they're a customer or not
we just want to prevent that
um and so we're able to go through these
two layers of security the internal
review
to prevent fraud and identity theft and
then the bitgo review
to prevent unauthorized sends um and
we currently the turnaround time on that
is less than 15 minutes
and we uh we um we confirm it one block
whereas coinbase convergence of three
so what you're looking at is a procedure
that is a security system that is more
decentralized
that has more layers of approval um but
is in fact faster than coinbase
um and so that's the that's the answer
on the crypto side
the now let's talk about cash
the traditional way to store cash on a
crypto exchange
is in a type of custodial account called
a for benefit
of account and that is an account that's
in the company's name
that holds the cash of all the different
users and then
what the company does is keep a record
of how much funds are for the benefit of
each customer
and what you'll typically see
you'll typically see something in the
contract that i think is pretty scary
that says like we'll never voluntarily
give up your funds in an insolvency
event right
so if we get sued if we get if we go
bankrupt and we get in a
you know a bankruptcy proceeding we're
not going to voluntarily give up your
money
um but you know you do lots of stuff in
bankruptcy that's not voluntary
so we wanted to um we wanted to really
make sure that the cash is as safe as
possible
and the gold standard for storing cash
in the united states
is an ftic insured checking account and
your own name
because uh
because it's the best experience if we
fail you can log into that account you
can pull the cash we're not allowed to
touch it
um first of all we're not allowed to
direct funds
unless it's directly authorized by a
customer so the customer has to tell us
every time we direct funds second if
something happens to level
you just log in and you can pull the
cash off and then
third it's directly fdic insurance so if
there's a big
macro financial event um then the fdic
under the law will mail you a check for
the cash
um and i think that that that really is
sort of the highest
degree of confidence i think you could
have in cash under current north
american law
got it and it feels to me like uh
the security component is getting
figured out by a lot of people and
obviously there's been
less hacks uh which is a good thing
overall for the industry
fdic insurance is an absolute game
changer on the cash side
going to this model of having kind of
the
the true deposits rather than the
custodial deposits is another kind of
game changer
one of the other issues that's come up
on the crypto exchange side
is uh the treatment of private
information of the users
so there's been reports that some
exchanges have sold information
some are using it for other purposes
maybe just talk a little bit about kind
of what you guys see
on the industry um perspective and then
how you're looking at treating
uh individual private information
yeah so um so i want to preface this by
saying that like what i've seen on
twitter
is a lot of speculation and it's very
interesting to me like i would love to
like sit down with someone at coinbase
and just ask
how they actually handle some of these
things but i don't know for all i know
um
uh for all i i just cannot say that i
have
no coin basis policies um what i can do
is talk about the types of things that
come up that affect customer privacy and
in exchange
and how we've chosen to handle those um
so you know the first thing that we do
uh with our
the first thing when you create an
account that we ask a customer to do is
to apply
for their level account so you've signed
into the app but you can't operate you
can't
you can't access banking services until
we've verified your identity and this is
again to prevent fraud and identity
theft
it takes about two minutes we take a
picture of your photo id the front and
back
we automatically fill out all the fields
like your name and your address
we have you do a selfie video um that
authorizes the opening of the account
which which we also use to if you ever
get locked out we can look at that video
and make sure that it's you
um and then we get a record of your
social security number
um at that time
that is that is uh that is all exchanges
asked for this stuff
um uh a lot of them um
a lot of them might like like a
breadcrumb it you know ask for it one
step at a time like maybe you can buy
100 bitcoin
but now we need a picture of you now you
can buy a thousand but now we need your
social right
um we do that's because they they don't
want to
they don't want to get hacked right the
the less sensitive information they get
hacked for the better
for us we collect all that because
you're opening an fdic insured bank
account and the law requires that you
collect that
but what we do is we custody that with
our banking partner
that has decades of experience with no
with no vulnerabilities right um like uh
and
uh and then we pull information
only when we need it so like for example
if you buy a debit card
we're gonna send a request to the bank
get a copy of your address
uh and then confirm that with you and
then ship the debit card there
uh so um in that sense you know the
first line of defense about protecting
information is just to not have it
and and you know we're just designing to
not have that information
now um it is
true i i think i think it is very true
that there are
laws that have to be followed when
you're running a financial institution
um you know we're we we are
we are an exchange we're a financial
institution we offer ftic-insured
bank accounts um and i live in
los angeles not hong kong so
i have to follow these laws um now
what we are going to try to do as a
business is to be as
transparent as possible about what it is
that we're doing
um and i'm happy to talk about a couple
elements of that
here today um so uh
so first of all some exchanges have a uh
some exchanges have a blockchain
analytics unit um
and what those analytics do is they look
at transactions that are incoming to the
exchange
or that are leaving the exchange and
they they monitor for example
to make sure that you're not withdrawing
uh bitcoin to one of the addresses
associated with that that hack that
happened two days ago
um that's a totally different that's a
totally reasonable thing to do
right um but some exchanges also take
that
those tools that they've developed to
make sure that you know
funds aren't being sent to like kiddie
porn operations for example
which i think everyone would agree is a
good thing to stop they take those tools
that they've made available or that
they've developed internally and they
make them available to law enforcement
so law enforcement can now use these
blockchain analytics tools
that were developed by an exchange uh in
order to sort of in order to sort of
de-anonymize people on the blockchain
right
now you can also go a step further and
you could say
uh exchanges you can't track individual
users in exchanges just
it's just an idiosyncrasy of the way
that exchange wallets work
but an exchange that chooses to sell
that type of software to the government
could choose to um to basically split
out all their users
and their deposit addresses and their
withdrawal addresses to add more detail
to that map
on an anonymized basis and they could
even choose
to put the username and the you know the
username the date of birth the social
security number
in the de-anonymized version and sell
that to the government
um there's no law preventing that i
don't know that that
is what coinbase is doing um
but i can tell you that first of all
we do not sell analytics technology to
any
federal agencies and second
we do not provide personal information
on a customer
um basically with the same policy as
kraken like if you could if you subpoena
us
we will follow the law to the letter and
otherwise like you're not going to get
information from us
um and so uh uh so an example of that
would be like um there's a there's a
thing called a 314b
which is basically a report you thought
because you saw something suspicious
that you're just voluntarily um giving
that information to the government
we don't file 13 314 b's we don't think
that it adds value
and then places where we do report to
the government because
again we're required by law we're going
to follow the law i don't want to go to
jail
um what we try to do is be as
transparent as possible
to the customer um so we don't want
there to be any ambiguity about what we
provided or why we provided it
so for example the internal revenue
service requires
a requires a report
if you do more than 40 000 of payment
transactions on a platform in a year
so uh what we do is we of course
file that but we we strip it down to the
most anonymized form
that we can no you don't can't see who
the counter parties were
the type of trades whatever we give them
the absolute
bare minimum to be in compliance with
the law um
and i don't think we're trying to
withhold anything from them we just want
to respect customer rights
as we submit that then what we do is we
email the customer and say hey this is
what we sent to the irs
here's the reason we sent it to the irs
by the way
here's the information that you need for
your 1099b for your tax filings
and here's your transaction summary and
here's your 8949
like cost basis summary so we're
basically
going to follow the law and then we're
going to give the user all the
information they need to be fully
empowered about their rights
um and if i could just give one more
example
just because it's specific to us being a
financial institution that offers bank
accounts exchanges aren't required
to let you know if they sell customer
data
for marketing purposes or if they sell
customer data
um uh for marketing purposes by their
affiliates or if they do joint marketing
they're not required by law to disclose
that a bank
is required by law to disclose that and
so once a year you get let's say you
bank with wells fargo
once a year you're going to get a letter
that says here's all the information
we're selling
and you know if you want to opt out you
need to make 10 phone calls and send six
emails right
um in our app there's a privacy notice
and basically we use your personal
information
to send transactions that you initiate
and we don't market with affiliates we
don't sell with affiliates we don't
market to third parties we don't sell to
third parties
and that is disclosed on an annual basis
and right in the app you can see it
um so our our model does not require us
to make money from the government it
does not make require us to make money
by trying to sell you car loans
and we just don't do any of that why
like when i hear that that all sounds
great why do you choose to go down this
path and others don't
um how could i speak to the motivations
of other people i mean obviously it's
lucrative
i think for us we're a services business
and our customer is the
uh our customer is the trader
um is our customer is the level member
um if we were selling this technology to
the government
our customer would be the government and
then maybe our product is customer
information
but the only customer that we have is
the level member
and if i was a level member i wouldn't
want any of that information
shared unnecessarily i
i would want to know if information was
shared i would want to be notified
and i think i think it's really just the
bottom line is
the people we serve our customers and
and we don't have conflicting
financial interests that i think would
compromise us in this area
yeah that's not a bad way to look at it
um talk
through a little bit about how you're
seeing um
users use the product so far right so
you kind of have two different
products in terms of a cash product and
a crypto product uh you take a very kind
of customer centric or customer first
approach
what are users doing when they come on
are they putting you know all of their
money in the
deposit account are they putting all
their money in crypto are they splitting
it like what do you see there from user
behavior
yeah great question so there are three
central components of our product
there's our banking product
our crypto product and our customer
support product
so uh the main product today
that is going to save people a lot of
money just right out the gate
is our crypto product and
that's because uh that's because as i
mentioned with with
very low trading on other platforms it
pays for itself
um and it's also because we have we have
autopilot
and so all the all that sweet market
making income that coinbase
has been keeping for themselves you can
put your bitcoin in there and passively
earn an income that way
um and all of that stuff is running
today
um we also are seeing a lot of
engagement with the support chat
and uh i i really want to emphasize like
how much
that we've tried to make that a good
product
right so many support systems are
designed to to be like
how can i not have to deal with these
people right like first i'm gonna give
you a robot
if you negotiate with the robot or like
match zero over and over and over again
then like maybe i'll let you talk to a
human but it's not gonna be the human
you wanted to talk to
and then like we're just gonna
disconnect if we get frustrated with you
right
um our support product isn't like that
at all it's a chat you have with an
assigned
banker and that banker is there to help
you navigate the product and that's
provided
free of charge so we're seeing a lot of
people go engaged with those
bankers and sometimes it's i initiated a
withdrawal
what's the typical time that it takes
for that to
to settle um sometimes it's like
hey i really like it but you know did
you know about this bug on the buy
screen
um but we're seeing about two out of
five people are going and engaging with
support and that's exactly what we want
like you're not we're not going to give
you a canned response that says like hey
have you seen this support article
we're going to talk to you because
that's the expectation you that is what
you expect
when someone is banking for you right
we're not exchanged we are banking for
you
um and then the banking side uh we are
seeing people deposit a lot of money
the main reason you would do that today
is to facilitate
um purchasing crypto or liquidating
crypto
by the end of this year we'll have a
debit card uh and you can receive
paychecks
deposit checks and send checks from
level uh
so there's there's no reason that you
wouldn't use this to replace both wells
fargo
and coinbase and like in addition to the
benefit of it just being a good
experience and being affordable you
wouldn't have to move money between them
anymore
um but what we're seeing people do today
is save a lot of money on crypto trading
and talk to our support team so
already it's pretty compelling obviously
uh we invested
in you know my personal fascination is
just this idea of
uh can you completely disrupt an
industry that is highly highly
profitable by simply
changing the way that you get paid right
and so uh rather than the transaction
fees if you go to the subscription model
uh i ran the math and it's look you know
coinbase would have made more money in
2017
by having everyone pay nine dollars a
month uh that was part of their user
base
rather than have them just make the
billion plus dollars they made on
transaction fees
all right so the subscription model
works in in that sense
now in terms of uh where you guys go
from here
what are kind of other products you're
thinking about other areas that are
interesting and kind of maybe other
bodies of work that uh that you guys may
or may not
end up working on so our mission
is to build the best financial
institution in the world
and a financial institution as a bank
first of all it's a place where you can
collect your paycheck and
and uh you know deposit checks and
basically be the place you keep your
money
um but we think that we think the
ecosystem is rapidly
evolving um and so you know for us to
offer
a bank if we want to launch the best
financial institution
and we didn't support crypto that would
be like launching a new
laptop in 2002 that doesn't support
wi-fi right
um you know or you launch the imac
without connecting to the internet
so it's it's [ __ ] like we fundamentally
have to be part of this this this
change that's going on from sort of
government
issued funny money to to money that we
can all really trust
like like we want to bank your money and
bitcoin is better money than cash so
like we're going to bank that right
as we look beyond that and of course we
have the customer support features
as we look beyond that uh we
are planning to add more states so we
support 60 of the population today
um we expect to support everywhere but
new york
by um early 2021.
uh that's a that is a a an incremental
change and if you sign up now you'll
receive a notification email once your
state is open
the other thing we're doing is we're
offering we're adding by the end of this
year
a debit card and the ability to do
direct deposit
and deposit checks so at that point
what you have is a bank that's
completely at parity
with something like chime or wells fargo
mobile
but is built for you has great customer
support
and and that's where we see people going
basically being able to live off this
product right um
i mean you could you could never deposit
cash once onto this platform
just use it to store bitcoin and pay
your bills with your debit card
um it's just a radically new approach to
banking
and we're in early access now during
early access at the end of the year
those features will be deployed and then
and then we will be a full production
product
um beyond that uh i'd say the major
initiatives that we're looking at is we
would love to support
the eurozone the united kingdom uh
canada new zealand and australia
as a start because it is our goal to be
the best
financial institution in the world and
the most reasonable place to start
is in um financial systems that are a
lot like ours
uh and with customers that have a lot of
the same similar expectations
and the other thing that we'll look at
is adding stocks
i think there's a big opportunity to
make um
stock investing better um part of it is
is if you want to invest in stocks you
need to move
cash from your bank account into a
brokerage account
and just like we want you to be able to
buy bitcoin right out of your checking
account you ought to be able to buy
stocks
right out of your checking account and
then you know that's part of the
motivation
uh another part of the innovation is we
want to get rid of these hidden spreads
that robinhood charges
um we want to educate the market on that
and and have our customers feel
confident that their subscription
is the only fee that they're paying um
and then the the final part of that
would be taking
autopilot which is our technology for
automating trading today
and and evolving into something that can
manage your whole portfolio
how much bitcoin are you huddling how
much are you
market making with the autopilot do you
have a diversified portfolio of etfs
um you should be able to invest from
your checking account
and liquidate back into your checking
account without leaving the app and have
that investing experience be able to
meet
all of the needs as you invest you know
your
your cash for the your cash or bitcoin
money for the future
explain a little bit more about what
autopilot does right now
yeah so um
so at a high level what autopilot does
is it allows you to take
bitcoin that you would otherwise be
huddling and move it into the autopilot
account
and it will automatically invest uh
those crypt those assets
on your behalf um so how does it invest
it
is it like crazy voodoo machine learning
it's not
it's it's doing a process called market
making and market making is one of the
like
oldest most proven and consistently
profitable ways to make money
in all of investing and it follows the
simple
the simple rule of buy low sell high so
a market maker let's say you got
you've got ten thousand dollars of
bitcoin on your account you've got ten
thousand dollars of cash on your account
and bitcoins trading at ten thousand
dollars so what i'm going to do
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take my cash i'm going to offer to buy
at a discount so i'm going to offer to
buy at 99 950.
that means anyone that trades with you
is paying you a 50 profit
for each bitcoin that they buy then i'm
gonna take all my cash
uh sorry uh that's with cash then i'm
gonna take my bitcoin
and i'm offered to sell that at a point
five percent premium so ten ten thousand
dollars fifty dollars
and so um anybody that buys that you're
making
fifty dollar profit for for the bitcoin
um
and uh so what autopilot does is it runs
that strategy
based on the current price estimate from
our partners over economics
and it runs that strategy 24 hours a day
and it reprices your orders every 15
seconds so
this is like a high frequency trading
tool
that is running like a a proven strategy
for consistently earning income
and the way it earns that income is when
people go on our platform
and they just buy or sell using the
standard interface
that's a market order and it's going to
consume some of these
uh amms liquidity uh and so
um during alpha uh we were
uh we're gonna have to see what happens
during prod like we are we're gonna have
a big birth like a big growth of supply
uh and then while demand is ramping up
or will there be a lot more demand than
supply as the as the marketplace
balances out but you know during alpha
we were seeing we're seeing people get
about a six percent monthly return
on their auto pilot funds as the while
the
markets were active um the final thing i
want to touch on
is it was really important for us to uh
to introduce a a strategy an automated
strategy that lets you participate
in the crypto market but passively um
and we didn't want it to be voodoo
um so the specific implementation that
we've made
is uh it's based on state-of-the-art
research
um uh on stochastic optimal control and
it's proven to be the optimal strategy
for market making
it's what the wall street guys are doing
it's what the chicago guys are doing
modern market makers run this algorithm
and we're making it available to
to everyone you can learn more about
this strategy
uh uh by clicking the more info button
on your automated market maker and that
includes a link to the research paper
where we developed it
yeah it's really cool i think how what
you're basically saying is you're giving
the market making profit to
the user and also making sure there's
liquidity on the platform right is that
generally correct yes that is 100 it's
both those things
and then also what we're doing is we're
taking
we're taking another one of these hidden
fee business models
and we're getting rid of it because if
you go on coinbase consumer today
you're going to have a uh you're going
to have a commission fee which is 1.5
percent
and then that is subject to a minimum
right 0 to 50 that's a dollar beyond
that is two dollars it goes up to three
dollars
um so that's their commission what
they're not telling you is that they
also
increase the price by 0.5 percent so
coinbase is market making directly to
their consumer clients
um we are also eliminating that now
there's still a fundamental need to
market make and we're going to let our
customers
earn the profit by delivering value
market making but
we are removing ourselves as a market
making participant
an intermediary such as coinbase wood
got it what uh what do you think the
biggest obstacle for growth for you is
moving forward
so we're really proud of our product
and we're not going to stop improving it
until like really every customer's happy
and i can't stress that enough i mean
every day we go through our chats from
the previous day we prioritize things
that we need to fix
um we burn them down through the day i
mean just today the whole team is
working on changing some aspects of the
referral program
um and the reason i emphasize that is
as i said it's an enormous amount of
trust to put your money on our platform
and the the number one most important
thing that we need to do
is make it easy to use at a fair price
and so nothing is a higher priority than
that we want to what we want
we want to earn trust in the business
model and the quality of the product
now beyond that it's it's sort of
evident that we need to get a certain
amount of customers
before this business model really works
right
um even though even though the per
transaction cost
for us is low we have uh we have
subscriptions to various pieces of
software we have employees to pay right
and so so we need to um we need to grow
to a sufficiently sized user base to be
sustainable and offer this free trading
forever
um which is which really needs to be a
community effort
um we're asking that
and and and i guess one way to say it is
like we always want to deliver more
value
than we're than we're asking in return
but we are going to ask people on the
platform
to to talk to other people about what
they've seen
there's tools to share it on twitter
there's ways to text message your
friends
um we're not forcing you to do it we
want you to to look around the product
um we are giving we're giving rewards
and consideration of your time so you
get ten dollars just for signing up
your friends you invite they get ten
dollars for signing up
once you have three friends that have
downloaded the app they don't even have
to be a paying customer yet
just that they've downloaded it we're
going to give you 10 bucks
um and then beyond that you know we'll
we'll pay you 30 of the of the
the membership fee that we collect from
people that you refer forever so that's
24
a year um as long as your friends are
our users
now like why are we doing that because
to get the word out
you have to do marketing and to do
marketing costs money
and the we think the ideal way to do
that would be to impress our customers
enough with whether they don't mind
sharing it
and because that's value to us we're
going to pay you and we'd rather pay you
than google or facebook it's it's really
that straightforward
yeah i love that um and talk a little
bit more about the
uh promotion that you're running right
now when somebody
signs up for an account then if they get
their friends to sign up
um kind of how that works and kind of
what the incentives are for people to
join like you're talking about there
so uh when you sign up through a
invite code so pomp's invite code for
example is lvl dot co
slash pomp if you follow that uh
you can download the app off the app
store you sign up for the account
and pomp is automatically going to get
credit for having referred you
um now when you sign up
uh the first thing we do is we just give
you ten bucks
like we're not going to charge you for
the first month we just give you ten
dollars of bitcoin
uh we want it to be completely free to
you to be able to poke around the
platform see if you like it
and if what you want to do with that ten
dollars is just withdraw it off the
exchange
um like bummer but you're allowed to do
that too
it's your ten dollars for giving it to
you just to sign up
next if you like the product and you
decide to share it with three friends
by text message or by posting a link on
twitter once we see that
three friends have downloaded the app we
credit you with another ten dollars
uh so that's twenty dollars and um so
far what you've had to do is download
the app
play with it text it to three friends
and see if they want to download it
right
um so you can earn twenty dollars just
by getting involved on the very first
day
uh so then downstream of that um
uh once let's say that you have five
friends that sign up
and they all become users they really
enjoy using it
um we're gonna be making recurring
revenue off them um
and so we're gonna give you a recurring
reward too um
you'll get two dollars for each of your
friends that are active in perpetuity
forever uh so four referred friends are
getting paid 100 bucks a year
uh and uh and and
the idea is like we want to ask you for
the minimum amount
to do to show that we have value right
so like thank you much for so much for
signing up like we really appreciate it
we knew that took time out of your day
here's 10 dollars because we want you to
play with that money not your own money
we think we can get your trust right
then you know when sharing with your
three friends to download
like you don't need to convince them to
use it we're not going to force you to
do it
but if you do it thank you so much for
your time here's 10 bucks and if they
convert we're going to give you some of
the rev share
we want it to be completely voluntary
but we want to show the
deep gratitude we have for people that
help make this company a success by
bringing it to scale
got it and i guess as you think about
the industry
kind of much larger just outside of you
guys
uh where are we going right so it it's
very obvious that
infrastructure has been a great business
to be in in
crypto and in the legacy fiat world
where is this all going and kind of how
do you see this developing over let's
maybe the next five years or so
yeah so that's a great question and i
think it's possible to answer that from
two different contexts like one of them
is like
where what's where's crypto head right
and like how does that affect the crypto
platform
and then the other is is uh is where a
financial service is set up
um and so um i'll start with crypto
if that's okay um you know i think
like like let's talk about bitcoin um
you know bitcoin
is uh it's decentralized
it's a payment method you don't have to
worry about people printing more of it
um and so it is just intrinsically
a uh it is intrinsically
a hedge against the us dollar um and
basically charges the us government
every time they print more money
that's what holding bitcoin does in
addition because it's a payment
mechanism
if we were to take bitcoin transactions
build easier to use
products where it's easier to pay for
things with bitcoin as we're going to
try to do with level
um if we're able to drive the
transaction volume
of people paying with bitcoin um
we would see the price of bitcoin go up
by a factor of 100.
um it's also true that we can get
transaction volumes
up high enough where it's more cost
competitive relative to debit cards
which costs one to 1.5 percent uh fee
to process right as you know bitcoin has
a
simple flat rate fee um and so
uh bitcoin makes a lot of sense
to own as an investment to help be a
part of promoting its
adoption as a payment mechanism and so i
think
today uh uh offering crypto as part of a
financial product is
absolutely essential i would not feel
responsible
building a bank where users can't bank
crypto
if that makes sense um so that's where i
think kryptos headed
uh the financial services
um what we're seeing right now is
uh a lot of companies that have started
in different areas
trying to sort of complete to be the
complete financial institution of the
customer
and everyone is starting from a
different vantage point and they're
taking a different approach
so i'm just going to name a couple at
random robinhood started as a
stock broker account now they want you
to keep your cash there
but they don't have checking accounts
they don't have demand deposit accounts
fdic insured accounts
so that they have to they call their
program for holding cash they call it
cash management because that cash is
being held in an
sipc account you see the same thing with
uh
betterment um so that's one approach
right
then you've got uh you've got venmo so
now venmo
wants to to keep some of your money um
and what the way that they're doing that
is basically by loading a card
so like under the hood they have a cash
account and it's basically
it's just credit on a payment network
and they'll
send it back to you um uh so you know
that's not a real
checking account and there's also the
issue that you know if you fund that
with a debit card it's a four percent
fee
right and so um so
uh there's a clear advantage when you
have a financial institution that can do
all of these things
uh like if you have one app where you
can buy stocks and
you know there's no hidden fees where
you can buy krypto and you know there's
no hidden fees uh
where you can bank where you can spend
on a debit card if for some reason you
run out of cash
it just covers the overdraft with your
bitcoin there are so many benefits to
that
not to mention just cutting down on the
fees that you would have paid
moving money from coinbase to wells
fargo right um there's just an
incredible number of benefits and so
what we're seeing is a lot of companies
um that are trying to collect the
infinity stones they need to get the
banking infinity stone
they need to get the brokerage infinity
stone they need to get the
crypto infinity stone and if they can
get all the right infinity stones they
can
be this trusted digital financial
institution
um that obviously is our goal
what we're trying to do is take the most
principled approach that we can
on every aspect every pillar that we add
to the product
so our checking account it is not cash
in a preloaded debit card
it is not an sipc account brokerage
account it is an
it is not a custodial account where
we're looping together with other funds
and just hoping it goes well
it is a bank account and it's a bank
account that
uh comes with all the same guarantees
you would have it at wells fargo
including from the fdic
right when we did crypto we don't want
to do
a stripped-down version of crypto like
like
um like robin hood would do where you
can buy crypto but you can't actually
send it
and when you buy it you're always going
to be paying
a markup to um to coinbase or sorry to
to robinhood
we want to do it where it's just a spot
market we don't participate in it
like you can make liquidity and make
money you can buy crypto and make money
it's just totally up to you and then you
know as we move forward to other things
that we add we're going to be just as
principal
um now who gets there first
uh who is who you know who's the
favorite platform
i don't know but i can tell you that um
i can tell you that
our business model is transparent and we
have been laser focused on doing each
aspect
of this financial institution in the way
that our customers think
we believe that our customers would
expect from us
make sense to me what is um
the place that we want to send everyone
to go and find out more about
level yeah so um
if you're i would i would recommend i'll
give you a couple of resources
first of all it uh there's no harm in
trying out the app
go to lvl.com tone oh sorry
leo.com sorry about that come on give me
you got to get me my credit i know i was
on i was on
i was i was did a video with uh tone
yesterday so i'm just like
like mushy brain i'm so don't listen to
that guy come on come on into lvl.co
slash pop
yep lvo.com if you didn't get that
lvl.com
so look if you go to lvo.com you're
going to be brought to the app store
you're going to download it
there's no commitment whatsoever you can
log into the app you get your credited
bitcoin you can look around you can
explore
every single feature it's up to you
whether you want to complete
the verification it's up to you whether
you want to share it with other people
um the entire app is open faced at the
second you log in you can see everything
that the app does explore the entire
thing
so i would strongly encourage you to go
to lvl.com
and just try it out in addition to that
you can go to lvl.co and we have
information on the platform
including the states that it's available
in 26 states and 60 percent of the us
population
uh we also have a twitter a bank with
level and
uh we use that twitter to to basically
engage with people
uh and right now as the platform is
really in its infancy
you have a really strong voice so if you
tweeted us and you're like i hate this
feature
like please fix it there's a really good
chance it's going to get fixed
that day if not that week um and so i
would also just highly encourage you
engage with us there because
i mean basically people snapping at us
on twitter is like it's like our that's
our new boss
as we're getting this rolled out i love
that
uh before i finish up i always ask the
same two questions first is uh what is
the most important book that you've ever
read
most important book that i've ever read
so i got this last time
and so i'm going to try to think of
something different
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say the great
gatsby
um so last time i did a non-fiction book
about like vulnerability now i'm gonna
say the great gatsby because
it is just such a well-written book
um and we could say this is second most
important because i do think it's very
important to like understand
vulnerability and be a healthy adult
um but you know if you want to read a
book that's just
a work of freaking art that you know
you're just really going to appreciate
that there's smart people out there
writing books
uh totally recommend the great gatsby if
you haven't read it
that is a great one uh any new thoughts
on aliens there's been videos that have
come out
there's all kinds of new developments so
like there have been a lot of new
developments and i think the answer that
i gave you last time
was like of course there's aliens like
like there's so many stars there's so
many planets you know
but now i'm not so sure because i was
reading about
i was reading about i think it's called
the fermi paradox which is like
which is like if there's so many aliens
why aren't we seeing any of them and
like i just like i just like read
through that wikipedia page
like like all day um i mean not all day
but like i read through that and
it made some pretty compelling arguments
like we should be able to see radio
signatures
we've like really swept the sky um
also the idea that like advanced
civilizations would build super
structures
um and those superstructures would have
certain like marks that would be easy to
identify
um and then that got me down the path of
like well if we can't see that
you know is is there some great filter
thing where like civilization gets far
far enough along they build some
doomsday device and then wipe themselves
out
um and that was suppressing so i stopped
thinking about it uh that's why
that's my download
you went did research though i i'll take
credit for you going and doing research
what up you made me think what uh what
question you got for me to finish this
thing up
um so the last time
i asked you um i think that
i think that i i think the last time i
asked you how you balance
um having a podcast with being an
investor
um and so i'm going to ask you the easy
one this time which is just like i need
a download on your view on aliens
yeah there's definitely aliens the the
two key qualifiers of that
are uh aliens being other life
or other intelligent life you could
categorize it either way if you just go
other life
for sure because you just need organisms
uh they're probably on mars right
there's water on mars
um and then the second thing is just
from a time perspective are we here on
the same time scale
so let's say that uh you know there
could have been
other life a billion years ago but
humans weren't around
or yeah life could be a billion years
from
today and humans won't be around i don't
know um but i definitely think that
there's life it's just a matter of
um you know kind of are we here at the
same time and uh is it intelligent or
not
yeah i'd buy that like we're we're on a
very
small court of time on a cosmic scale
you know
we're we're like like 0.001 like we're
gonna live 80 years out of 13.8 billion
um so yeah i mean that
i totally buy that um i just i it's just
depressing if you think about the
the great filter but it's totally
plausible that we just we just missed
these guys
it's depressing man when you start
thinking of that it's like hey let's go
do some crazy wild stuff while we're
here because we ain't here for very long
right
exactly all right man i love it uh
everyone go to
lvl.com we're super excited
like i said we invest in the business uh
i really think that this idea of
a nine dollar a month flat fee uh could
be quite disruptive in the market and
frankly it's just better for users so
guys go check it out and uh chris we'll
do this again sometime soon
yeah it sounds great thanks so much for
having me